a three billion dollar spacecraft  hurtles towards destruction  [Music]  this is no accident  [Music]  it's a sacrifice to protect what this  mission has revealed including a moon  with the building blocks of life  I have liquid water you have energy in  you have organic materials so if there's  anywhere in the solar system other than  earth where some kind of life could  exist it could very well be at Enceladus  with fuel tanks almost empty Cassini's  time is up  it cannot be allowed to fly on any  longer there's a theoretical chance that  microbes from Earth could have survived  on board  we can't risk contaminating the world  where life could evolve untouched by  human colony it's a spectacular end of  an extraordinary mission taking us  closer to Saturn than ever before  [Music]  [Music]